Tyler what's been your experience
looking for an agent or manager I know
you came from New York from the modeling
world and you did acting as a child as
well what's your process like looking
for an agent or manager well I would say
that one thing that a lot of people I
think forget when they're soliciting
representation is that it's as much an
interview for you as it is interview for
them and it it really is not a question
of who you're working with or the size
of the agency I think it really has to
do with the passion that your your
representative has for you and and as
such I think a lot of times as actors we
go into these meetings looking for a
certain outcome and just all too eager
to sign on the dotted line when we hear
the things we want to hear when in
reality you know there are a lot of hard
questions that you have to ask in
Reverse and sometimes hard to do as an
actor because you know there's a lot of
insecurity in this business I mean the
one thing that I've always been reminded
of and my mom does it does so lovingly
but also to make sure I stay responsible
but is that the second you finish the
your last job you're unemployed so and
that's the nature of this of this job so
sometimes when you're going for these
meetings and whatnot you feel like
you're in a like you're back on your
heels as opposed to you know where you
should be which is firm and centered and
and how can we work together to achieve
a mutually desired result and outcome so
so for me that means I have some
questions when I go in there to but I've
been lucky enough especially recently
just to come across a great team a
fantastic team who I really believe in
and it's a and it's very and we're very
new to one another so I'm very excited
for the future I know I've talked to
other actors and they've said that you
know they felt that they're at their
agent or manager wasn't giving them the
attention that they need and they
understood because they had quote bigger
clients to deal with but if if an
actor's feeling that like maybe phone
calls aren't returned
then you know like at what point do they
say either I'm being too demanding or
though these are red flags and I need to
move on I mean that is also a great
question that's tough to say because I
think that there are two sides there are
two sides to that on one side I think a
lot of times actors rely too heavily on
their managers they they lean on them
and their agents representation and they
become their representation becomes a
sort of scapegoat for for the the
success that maybe they're not having at
the moment when I feel like a lot of
rather than turn it externally I feel
like a lot of the works we turn
internally and you have to you have to
really ask yourself have I done
everything that I could possibly do for
me I noticed to get into the specifics I
noticed that for years and years as an
actor I really wasn't aware of the
materials that were being pitched on my
behalf things like actors access and lay
casting those sorts of those sorts of
different houses and and it wasn't until
recently that I really started checking
the materials to make sure they're up to
date and lo and behold and here do I
find here the relics of all these old
agents that I've been with and here's
you know misattributed credits or
missing credits or all these kinds of
things so you know for me I think before
you go blaming others just like in life
you got to ask yourself have I done
everything and and for me that really
comes down to not just 90 percent not
just 95 percent not even 99% but am i
doing a hundred percent of what I could
possibly do to help my case and then at
that point then I've turned the blame to
the representation and then you make
decisions from there but unfortunately
hasn't gotten to that
you